The tiny carnivorous snowmen are relentless
- sharp fangs dripping with blood, as they
crawl en masse towards the Mobile Task Force,
opening fire on them with assault rifles.
Who would have guessed that a mere hour or
two earlier, a young boy was joyfully playing
around in the snow here?
How had things gone from frosty to freaky
so fast?
Let’s rewind the clock…
There was a chill in the air, that lingering,
biting cold that would gnaw at your exposed
skin if you dared to step outside in anything
less than a thick, warm coat for protection.
The ground was still coated in a heavy snowfall,
a holdover from Christmas just passed, weather
that had refused to let up well into the early
days of the New Year.
Everyone reaches an age where the cynicism
of life, the weight of expectations that keep
you anchored in the real world, they all coalesce
to rob you of the childlike wonder at the
snow.
As you get older, the snow loses its novelty,
it becomes a source of inconvenience, something
you need to shovel off the driveway to take
your car out.
Whereas, turn the clock back to youth, and
it’s like a tiny miracle, it coats your
whole world in a clean blanket of freezing
frosting, turning the ordinary into a wonderland.
Robert and Mikaylah Anderson were glad that
their son, Michael, was still at an age where
he could enjoy the snow.
After all, Mikaylah getting to take her son
out in his sled or seeing him hurling snowballs
at Robert was able to provide them with a
little bit of warmth during the freezing cold,
snowier months in Missouri.
Optimism was never enough to melt the snow,
however, and maybe that’s what drew in those
creatures…
the snowmen.
It was early 2019, not even a full two weeks
into the year.
By now, Michael had gotten used to the fact
that after Christmas and New Year’s Day,
a begrudging return to school would soon follow.
As much as it clearly brought down his mood,
nothing lifted his spirits like still getting
to be out in the snow.
And after a long day of helping his mom take
down the tinsel and pack up the lights while
his dad disposed of the tree, Michael was
itching to get outside.
“Please, Mom?” he begged as a box of decorations
was placed back in the attic; his hands clasped
together in a pleading gesture.
“Please, please, please!
Just five minutes, I won’t go further than
the front yard!”
Mikaylah sighed, partly from exhaustion, but
a smile crept onto her face; it was hard not
to find her son’s love for the snow endearing.
“Alright, but only for five minutes!”
she insisted firmly.
“And I want to see gloves, hat, and scarf,
not just a coat, mister!”
With the speed and excitement that she and
her husband had long since lost, she watched
Michael race off to gather his warmest winter
coat.
“Remember when we were like that?”
Robert heaved a sigh as he appeared from chopping
up the dried-out, dehydrated remains of the
Christmas tree.
“No, do you?”
Mikaylah replied with a light chuckle.
Before long, Michael had donned his gloves
and coat, almost a size too big.
His scarf was almost wrapping up his entire
head, save for the bobble hat that poked out
at the top.
Robert opened up the front door, and his son
stepped out into a world that had been whitewashed
with clear, cold snow.
Given that the Andersons lived on a small
street in Grain Valley, there weren’t many
other people around, especially not with another
flurry of snowfall moving closer in the clouds
up above.
But it wasn’t the next snowfall that the
residents of Grain Valley, Missouri, should
have been worrying about; it was the previous
one, the one that had already fallen… and
what was now hiding among the snow in the
Anderson family’s front yard.
Having few other kids his own age to play
with, and not being allowed to venture too
far from the front porch, Michael was content
to spend his precious time outdoors making
snow angels, or practicing throwing snowballs.
He had long been trying to get one to clear
the roof of the small house he and his parents
shared, leaving a few scattered patches of
snow embedded on the roof shingles.
A few meters from the front door stood a snowman.
Granted, that was hardly a rare sight at this
time of year, especially in the cold weather.
But what was so unusual about it was, that
Michael hadn’t remembered making a snowman
recently.
His parents hadn’t let him out in the snow
on his own since the start of the New Year,
given how badly the downfall and icy winds
had been for the first week of January.
Sure, somebody else could have made it, taking
a pause as they passed by the Anderson’s
front yard.
Although, not Michael nor either of his parents
had spotted anyone doing that.
The snowman itself was featureless, the white
of its ice-cold body smeared with mud and
dead leaves, debris that had been packed in
with the snow used in its crude construction.
It was featureless too.
Whoever had made it hadn’t gone to the effort
of giving it a face, nor draped an old scarf
over it, or given it a hat.
It just stood there, but not like any other
snowmen; there was nothing welcoming about
it.
In fact, it was, fittingly, cold.
Given how far away it stood, it was almost
as if it was watching the house.
Curiously, Michael began to approach the snowman.
Being only nine years old, his imagination
was immediately running with the possibility
that this snow and mulch construct could be
alive, much akin to the likes of Frosty the
Snowman.
Little did young Michael Anderson know that
he wasn’t far from the truth, although this
particular snowman wasn’t quite the happy,
jolly soul from the much-covered holiday song.
He hadn’t gotten that much closer to the
snowman when he heard something move nearer
to where he stood.
There was the rustle of leaves and the snapping
of small twigs coming from a bush next to
him.
Michael couldn’t see what it was, but it
was far too low to the ground and too close
to the house for it to be a bird.
Maybe a possum or raccoon had gotten trapped
in the thin branches and was now scrabbling
to try and free itself.
Diverting from approaching the snowman, he
walked closer to the plant.
As he did, the rustling got louder, more frantic…
almost hungry.
There wasn’t just one creature lurking out
of sight beneath the leaves, but lots of somethings…
Robert and Mikaylah had been sitting indoors
watching the TV when they heard a spine-chilling
scream coming from outside.
Instantly, they were both up on their feet,
racing towards the front door.
Robert threw it open, and Michael dashed inside
in floods of fearful tears.
“What happened, sweetie?”
Mikaylah asked concerned, brushing snowflakes
from her son’s coat.
“Are you okay?
Did you slip over?”
Through crying and sniffling, shaking uncontrollably
with how afraid he was, Michael couldn’t
find the words to answer.
Instead, he pointed through the still-open
door, directly at the snowman, still standing
at the edge of the front yard.
“How long has that been there?”
Robert wondered aloud, taking a single step
outside.
“Don’t, Dad!”
Michael screamed.
But it was already too late…
Something small and speedy had leaped out
of the snow in the front yard and latched
onto Robert’s leg.
He howled as he felt searing pain, bitten
by rows of tiny, pointed teeth as sharp as
needles and as bitterly cold as ice.
Stumbling back, Robert Anderson fell over
and landed on the floor of the front hallway,
inadvertently carrying whatever had attacked
him into his home.
Both Mikaylah and Michael screamed in fear
as the tiny creature clawed its way up Robert’s
leg while he swatted at it frantically, trying
to brush it away before it could get closer.
With a blind swipe of his hand, he knocked
the creature to the floor and clambered to
his feet, arms outstretched, keeping his wife
and son behind him, while staring in disbelief
at what had bitten him.
It was barely more than half a meter tall,
a tiny, white…
snowman.
Bulbous, bloodied eyes bulged from its head,
much like those of an insect.
Directly between the eyes was a hole, a mouth
not unlike a lamprey, lined with rows of sharp
teeth that all pointed inwards.
It reared up and lunged toward the Anderson
family in a display of aggression that caused
all three of them to jump, warily backing
away from the snow creature.
It was then that Robert and Mikaylah noticed
what had frightened their son so much.
Out of the corner of their eye, they both
simultaneously caught sight of the open front
door, and the yard beyond.
Wriggling through the snow, shifting it as
they moved, were even more of the creatures,
slithering towards the house like piranhas
catching the scent of blood in the water.
And standing ominously just beyond the driveway
was the snowman, as if it was a general commanding
its troops to storm the house.
The Andersons raced upstairs as the swarm
of snow creatures came spilling into the house,
crawling from the yard onto the floor and
piling on top of each other like ants to climb
the stairs.
Naturally, Mikaylah’s first instinct – as
well as protecting her son – was to call
the police.
While Robert held the door to their bedroom
shut, Mikaylah held Michael close and pleaded
with the local Grain Valley Police Department
to come and help them.
Although, they only seemed to take the call
seriously when Michael started screaming again;
one of the snow creatures had pushed its way
under the doorframe and was snaking its way
towards Robert to attack him, leaving a trail
of water behind it.
Stepping back and thinking fast, Robert grabbed
a hairdryer and switched it on full blast.
The sudden rush of electrically heated air
caused the toothy snow creature to retreat
into a corner.
Refusing to let up, Robert got closer and
kept the hairdryer trained on it, eventually
causing the creature to melt until little
more was left than a damp puddle.
But the victory was momentary; there were
still more of them crawling up the stairs
after the Andersons.
With their sharp teeth, they were gnawing
at the wood of the bedroom door, trying to
force their way inside…
Fortunately for Robert, Mikaylah, and their
son Michael, they wouldn’t be able to recall
the horrific events of January 12th, 2019,
for much longer.
By the time the local police arrived, it had
become clear to the officers responding that
they were well out of their depth, especially
when one of them was injured, suffering a
bite from a snow creature.
This was what led to the SCP Foundation being
called in, and within fifteen minutes, they
had dispatched Mobile Task Force operatives
to secure the anomaly.
Being some of the Foundation’s most highly
trained agents, it didn’t take long for
the MTF to neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures.
However, they quickly realized that the mysterious
snowman that had seemingly spawned the swarm
could not be melted by any conventional means,
nor would it deteriorate naturally on its
own.
A cover story was issued that Michael had
suffered an accident and fallen down an open
pothole that had become obscured by heavy
snowfall.
As a result, police officers were dispatched
to help him - although the injury sustained
by one officer due to a bite from a snow creature
was never explained.
Following this, the Anderson family was administered
amnestics, meaning they quickly forgot about
the whole terrifying ordeal.
Maybe it was for the best, however, young
Michael seemed irreparably changed.
He never went out to enjoy the snow again,
repeatedly suffering from nightmares about
the cold.
Meanwhile, the anomalous snowman was recovered
and thus designated as SCP-4230.
Immediately, the SCP Foundation did as their
organization does best and commenced testing,
with a human subject, no less.
They quickly discovered that SCP-4230 seemed
to generate a sort of field around itself,
that could trigger a distinctive physiological
change in any human being or animal that came
within six meters of the snowman.
This process became known under the designation
of SCP-4230-1.
It appeared that Michael Anderson had managed
to unknowingly escape this fate purely by
not getting too close to SCP-4230, staying
just far away enough so as not to trigger
SCP-4230-1.
The Foundation placed, D-19375, a member of
their D Class personnel, within this six-meter
radius of the snowman, and observed the gradual
changes he underwent over the following week.
For simplicity’s sake, we’ll refer to
D-19375 as ‘Frost’ a rather fitting moniker,
and you’ll soon see why.
Within a day of exposure to the snowman, Frost
complained to a Senior Researcher that he
felt a lot colder than usual, although he
exhibited no other observable symptoms, beyond
the coughing and sniffling of a common cold.
By the following day, Frost was far worse
for wear, appearing to have lost significant
body mass to the point where he appeared to
have been malnourished.
His cold-like symptoms had continued, accompanied
by disorientating dizziness.
And, as if all that wasn’t bad enough, his
skin tone had seemingly lost its natural pigment,
reduced to an unnaturally pale shade, as white
as snow.
Day three saw Frost’s body continue to change
rapidly at an alarming rate.
He was internally producing an unknown chemical
that looked to be responsible for enacting
certain alterations, namely the dissolving
of his femur and fibula.
The cold and dizziness were also now made
all the worse by the addition of pain to the
man’s lower body.
Frost even reported to Foundation researchers
studying him that every movement he was able
to make caused him to suffer extreme levels
of physical pain.
But yet, rather than attempt to cure his condition,
the Foundation apathetically observed, noting
down the process of SCP-4230-1.
Within five days of exposure to SCP-4230,
naturally occurring substances within Frost’s
body had traveled downwards and solidified.
This was then followed by the most shocking
stage of SCP-4230-1 process so far, and one
that made the Foundation realize that these
weren’t just changes: it was a transformation.
When day five saw Frost’s skeleton physically
reshaping itself, his head becoming a sphere
and his arms extending outwards like brittle
twigs, it soon became clear what was happening
to him: he was turning into a snowman.
Rendered immobile and blind, a week after
SCP-4230-1 began to take effect, Frost had
started to secrete an unknown substance.
This liquid lowered his body temperature,
freezing almost instantly, and turning his
skin into an icy, white mass… worryingly
similar to snow.
Sure enough, on the eighth day, the extent
of the SCP-4230-1 process was made evident.
Frost had already perished, his body now looking
identical to a plain, featureless snowman,
no eyes or face, just a blank, cold slate.
But underneath the outer layer of snow, Frost’s
bones and the rest of his organs were still
contained inside.
From the outside, though, he wasn’t even
human anymore, just an instance of what became
known as SCP-4230-A.
However, being turned into another snowman
by close proximity to SCP-4230 wasn’t even
the worst part…
By now, you might be wondering ‘what were
those snow creatures that attacked the Andersons?’.
You’d be forgiven for thinking that perhaps
these were rodents or other wild animals affected
by SCP-4230-1; after all, testing has shown
that the process doesn’t just alter human
physiology.
But these carnivorous, needle-toothed creatures
are known as SCP-4230-Bs, and they’re nasty
little critters, to say the least.
When a person – or animal – is turned
into a snowman during SCP-4230-1, becoming
one of these instances is far from the full
extent of the transformation.
The tests the Foundation conducted on Frost,
and presumably on numerous other D class personnel
as well, led to them discovering the further
alterations made when something becomes an
SCP-4230-A instance.
Their freezing, snow-encased bodies become
hosts for white, spherical eggs.
After a subject like Frost becomes an SCP-4230-A
snowman, these eggs will hatch within seventy-two
hours, producing up to nineteen instances
of SCP-4230-B creatures.
The Foundation was quick to examine these
bizarre snow spawn, gathering up as many as
they could for testing.
They found that instances of SCP-4230-B matured
to adulthood remarkably quickly, reaching
adulthood in fifteen seconds.
Destroying the eggs containing these creatures
seemed to be an effective way of preventing
swarms of SCP-4230-Bs from getting loose,
although the snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve this
result.
Also, the lifespans of the smaller snow creatures
only lasted for a total of twenty-four hours,
and they would melt away after a full day
of life, regardless of the surrounding temperature.
SCP-4230-Bs seemed uninterested in food that
was presented to them.
Specifically, one test involved giving a snow
creature a head of lettuce and a watermelon.
The creature regarded the fruit and vegetable
with little interest, even refusing to eat
either despite prompts from the researchers.
This painted the SCP-4230-Bs as exclusive
carnivores, which explained why they attacked
the Anderson family: they were trying to eat
them, hunting the Andersons as a pack.
Further testing into SCP-4230-Bs revealed
they had a weakness to heat above a temperature
of forty degrees Fahrenheit.
During another test, a D Class was sent into
a cell with ten of the carnivorous snow creatures,
armed only with a simple lighter, an emergency
flare, and one gallon of gasoline.
Immediately, all ten of the SCP-4230-Bs crawled
towards the man, hungry and determined him
as a new source of food.
That is, until they noticed the lighter he
was carrying.
The D Class frantically clicked at the spark
wheel, until the flame danced from the lighter,
causing seven of the creatures to back away
from the heat source cautiously.
The D Class was able to kill the remaining
three instances in self defense, causing them
to melt with little effort.
He was far luckier than the subject of the
next test would be…
Another D Class was placed in a holding cell
with three of the snow creatures, and much
like before, they instantly acknowledged his
presence and began approaching him.
However, the Foundation had sent this member
of D Class in completely unarmed, without
even so much as a match to defend himself.
The carnivorous beasts made short work of
their helpless victim, feeding on what was
left.
The Foundation was able to dispatch instances
of SCP-4230-B with relative ease.
Even without waiting for them to simply melt
after a day, the use of flamethrowers or drawing
them into warmer areas seemed effective enough
at destroying the small snowmen that hatched
out of SCP-4230-A bodies.
However, some bright spark at the Foundation
decided to test what would happen if the opposite
element was used against SCP-4230-B creatures.
Were they vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow-like substance themselves?
Another test was conducted to answer this,
which involved a small snowball being thrown
at one of the SCP-4230-Bs.
The result of that incident has been entirely
expunged from the Foundation’s archives,
but it’s a safe guess as to why.
Evidently, when attacked using snow or ice,
SCP-4230-Bs are seemingly able to adapt in
some way that is detrimental to their attacker.
Do they add snow to their mass, or become
even more aggressive?
It’s hard to say, given the redactions,
but the results of that final test were deemed
so catastrophic that the Foundation banned
any further testing that involved SCP-4230-Bs.
As for where SCP-4230 first came from, the
Foundation is still baffled.
The first reported incident involving the
killer snowman and the carnivorous creatures
it produced came when the Andersons found
themselves under siege by hungry SCP-4230-Bs.
Maybe the snowman is just a freak of nature,
or the result of an unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in on a snowstorm one fateful night.
Or perhaps SCP-4230 is something far, far
more vicious.
Whatever the case, we would recommend waiting
for the sun to come back out and the snow
to melt… just to be safe.
Now go and check out “SCP-4666 THE YULE
MAN” and “SCP -784 CHRISTMAS CHEER”
for more anomalous absurdity from the time
of the year when the weather outside is delightful,
but for the Foundation, things are truly frightful.